The following content is
provided by MIT OpenCourseWare
under a Creative Commons
license.
Additional information about
our license and MIT
OpenCourseWare in general is
available at ocw.mit.edu.
Good afternoon.
I hope you had a nice weekend.
Did you have a nice weekend?
Good.
Today, we are going to start
talking about the motion of
molecules.
We are first going to talk
about the translational motion
of molecules today and Friday.
And then we are going to talk
about the internal motion,
in particular the vibrational
motion of molecules and their
rotational motion.
That will be early next week.
First, transitional motion.
Certainly, the quintessential
equation that represents the
behavior of gases is,
of course, the ideal gas law,
P equals n over V times RT.
This equation accurately
represents the behavior of gases
at low pressures.
It is an empirical law,
of course.
It is a law that Boyle and
Charles discovered by doing
experiments.
They noted that as the
temperature is raised,
the pressure went up.
They noted as the amount of gas
or the number of moles of gas
added goes up,
the pressure goes up.
They noted that as the volume
of their gaseous container goes
up, the pressure goes down.
Literally, this is an equation
established by experiment and
just varying one variable at a
time.
And since it looked like the
pressure was directly
proportional to the temperature,
they wrote an equation where it
was directly proportional to the
temperature, etc.
And the proportionality
constant here was always this
one constant R,
no matter what gas you had.
But this ideal gas law
describes the macroscopic
properties of a gas.
And what I mean by macroscopic
properties are properties that
describe a collection of
molecules.
For example,
to really talk about a
pressure, you have to have a
collection of molecules.
We are going to talk about the
pressure due to one molecule,
but that is really just a
model.
If you want to talk about
pressure, you need to have a
collection of molecules.
If you talk about temperature,
it really only has meaning when
you have a collection of
molecules.
But what we want to understand
is what are the underlying
microscopic phenomenon that
gives rise to this macroscopic
equation or these macroscopic
properties.
We want to know what is going
on in terms of the behavior of
the individual particles,
the individual molecules that
make up this gas.
Inquiring minds want to know
what the temperature means when
we talk about individual
molecules.
And that is also was Maxwell
and Boltzmann wanted to know.
They wanted a microscopic
explanation for PV equal nRT.
And, to do so,
they put forth a theory called
the kinetic theory,
or the kinetic theory for the
behavior of gases.
And that is exactly what we are
going to take a look at here,
this kinetic theory.
We are going to do what they
did.
Basically, this kinetic theory
allowed properties of gases at
low pressures to be predicted,
and it allowed an understanding
of why some of the properties of
real gases at higher pressures
deviated from this ideal gas
law.
But, more importantly,
what it did was it allowed the
quantity pressure times the
volume **PV** to be understood
in terms of the motions of the
molecules.
And it provided a means to
understand this concept of a
temperature in terms of the
motions of the molecules.
And that is what we are going
to look at today.
We are going to see how we can
describe pressure and volume in
terms of the motion of the
molecules and temperature in
molecules.
That is our goal.
In order to do that,
the first thing we have to do
is to understand what we mean by
pressure.
For example,
if you have some gas here in a
container and you are measuring
the pressure of this gas in that
container, --
what you are really measuring
is the force that the gas exerts
on one of the walls of this
container.
That is, pressure is the force
exerted by the gas on one of
these walls.
It is the force per unit area
that is exerted on the walls of
that container.
That
is what pressure is.
But what Maxwell did,
--
-- and this is 1850,
1855.
What Maxwell did was recognize
that he could understand this
macroscopic pressure in terms of
the individual forces of the
molecules when they hit the
container.
In other words,
he proposed that this gas was
composed of these molecules and
that these molecules were
moving.
That was his proposal.
And that when they moved and
hit the walls of the container,
well, that was the force that
was exerted by the gas.
In other words,
the force was really the
individual forces,
F sub i,
here, of the individual
molecules.
That total force was the
individual force of the
molecules hitting the walls of
the container.
That is what led to this
macroscopic concept,
the macroscopic quantity of
pressure.
That was his idea.
Well, if that was his idea,
he carried it through,
now, to a prediction.
The idea is that this force
arises from the individual
forces of these individual
molecules hitting the walls of
the container.
Let's look at what theory he
wrote down.
His goal, here,
was to calculate these
individual forces,
F sub i.
And, of course,
go back to classical mechanics.
Force is the mass times the
acceleration,
the mass of the particle,
the molecule,
times its acceleration.
And acceleration we can write
just in terms of delta v over
delta t.
That is just the mass times
delta v over the change in time.
And if the mass is constant
here, this numerator,
that is the change in momentum
per unit change in time.
That is what this force is.
What we have to do,
here, is calculate the change
in the momentum of the wall when
the molecule hits the wall.
That will be the force of the
individual molecule in the wall,
that over the time between the
collisions of the molecule with
the wall.
That is the individual forces.
That is what we are trying to
calculate, right here.
Let's do that and calculate
delta p, the change in the
wall's momentum.
Let's do it in one dimension
first.
Here is our box.
This is just a cross-sectional
view of that box I drew over
here.
And this is going to be the
wall that we are going to be
interested in.
The box has a length l.
And we have this molecule with
some mass m.
It is coming into the wall and
is going to collide with it,
and it has some velocity vector
v.
But let's do it in one
dimension because it is simpler
to do.
And then we are going to extend
it to three dimensions in a few
minutes.
We are just going to do it in
one dimension now.
We are only going to be
interested in then the
x-component of the velocity of
this molecule coming into the
wall, and we want to know what
is the force exerted by this
molecule when it collides with
this wall.
First we have to get the change
in the momentum.
This molecule comes in and hits
the wall, and we are going to
consider it to be an elastic
collision.
If the component of the
velocity in the x direction
before the collision is v sub x,
then after the collision,
it is minus v sub x.
We have just changed the
direction of our velocity
vector, not the magnitude.
The change in the atom's
momentum, then,
is just the momentum after
minus the moment before.
The momentum after was m times
minus v sub x.
The momentum before,
m sub v sub x.
Delta in the change in the
atom's momentum,
is minus 2 m v sub x.
However, we have to conserve
momentum.
The momentum change in the atom
plus the momentum change in the
wall has to equal zero.
And what we want to know is the
momentum change in the wall,
because we are after this
macroscopic quantity,
pressure.
And so, if the change in the
momentum of the atom is minus 2
m v sub x,
then the change in the
momentum of the wall is 2 m v
sub x .
We have one quantity here.
We have delta p.
But now, we have to calculate
how often that momentum in the
wall changes due to this
molecule's collisions.
We need the delta t.
And so, what happens here?
The molecule comes in,
collides, and then reflects.
And the molecule is now going
in this direction,
where it hits the back wall,
and then it reflects.
And ultimately it comes back
and hits the front wall.
And what we want to know is
what is the time here between
the collisions.
The time between when that
molecule makes the momentum in
the wall change.
What is this time,
delta t?
Well, if we know the length of
the box and we know the value of
v sub x, we can calculate that
time.
That time is just two times the
length of the box because that
molecule is traveling back and
then forth, --
-- that is 2l divided by the
velocity component in the x
direction, v sub x.
That
is delta t.
Now we have delta p and delta
t, and we can plug that in and
make it simple a little bit.
And so, here is the force
exerted by the collision of one
molecule on that one wall of the
container, m v sub x squared
over l.
But we said that Maxwell's idea
was that the macroscopic total
force was the sum of these
individual forces.
What we have to do is take the
force of each individual
molecule and add them up over
all the molecules.
There is that force for
molecule one,
molecule two,
molecule three,
all the way up to molecule n.
I am going to pull out an m
over l out of this.
I just pull out an m over l,
and I have left the sum of the
squares of the velocities in the
x direction for each one of the
molecules.
Notice here,
in this treatment,
we have identical m's.
The particles are the same,
but, and this is important,
the velocities of the molecules
are not the same.
That is going to be important.
Now, this expression here,
I want to simplify a little
bit.
In particular,
I want to simplify the sum of
the squares of the velocity
components in the x direction
for each one of the molecules.
To do that simplification,
I am going to introduce this
quantity.
This quantity is the average of
the square of the velocity in
the x direction.
What this means is I take the
velocity in the x direction,
I square it,
and then I take the average.
This is not the square of the
average velocity in the x
direction.
That is different.
This is the average of the
square of the velocity in the x
direction.
How am I going to evaluate that
quantity?
Well, I am going to take the
velocity in the x direction for
molecule one and square it and
add to that the square of the
velocity in the x direction for
molecule two and add to that the
square of the velocity in the x
direction for molecule three,
all the way up to molecule n.
And then, if I want the
average, I am going to divide by
n, the number of molecules there
are.
I am just going to bring n,
here, over to the other side.
I have n times the average of
the velocity in the x direction
squared as this sum,
and this is exactly the sum
that I had in my expression for
the total force.
I can simplify that now.
There is that same expression.
Here is my total force.
What I am going to do is I am
going to substitute n times the
average of the velocity in the x
direction squared in for this
whole sum, and I have now
something that is much tidier.
That is the total force exerted
by all the collisions of the
molecules in the container on
that front wall.
But now I want the pressure.
And the pressure is just force
per unit area.
And so, I am going to take my
expression for the force and
divide it by the unit area.
The area is the area of this
wall, here, in my initial
example.
I am going to call that area A.
And if this is a Q,
and I am going to make it a Q
because it is easier to do it
that way, the area times the
length then of this box is just
the volume.
Here is the volume.
There is my expression for the
pressure due to all of the
molecule colliding with the
front wall of that box.
However, this is an expression
for the pressure in one
dimension only,
the x dimension.
And we know,
in real life,
we have three dimensions.
We have to take care of that.
Let's do that now.
Let's extend this problem to
three dimensions.
To do so, I am just going to
realize right here that the
square of the velocity is the
sum of the squares of the
components.
That, you understand.
That is okay.
What is not so obvious is this.
The average of the square of
the velocity is the sum of the
average of the squares of each
one of the components.
That is true.
You can prove that.
We are not going to prove that.
I won't hold you responsible
for proving that,
but that is true.
That is correct,
but now here comes a critical
assumption in Boltzmann's
treatment.
The critical assumption is that
the motion of the molecules in
this gas, here,
is random in the sense that the
molecules don't have a preferred
direction.
They are going in the x
direction as often as they are
going in the y direction as
often as they are going in the z
direction, so the motion is
random.
If that motion is random,
then the average of the
velocity squared in the x
direction is going to be equal
to that in the y direction.
It is going to be equal to that
in the z direction if that
motion is random.
And that is great because it is
going to make things a little
simpler for us up here.
If that is right,
then the average of the
velocity squared is three times
the average of the velocity
squared in any one of the
dimensions.
That is going to make it easy
to extrapolate this to three
dimensions because now I am
going to be able to substitute,
which had the average of the
velocity squared only in the x
direction, I am going to be able
to substitute in an expression
for the average velocity in
three dimensions.
That is just going to be
one-third that.
This is going to be one-third
the average of the velocity
squared.
That is great.
Now, I am going to do that
substitution way up into there.
And when I do that,
look at this.
I have a result.
This is the kinetic theory
result.
We just did exactly what
Maxwell did.
We have an expression for the
pressure times the volume,
which is written here in terms
of the average of the velocity
squared of the molecules.
It is written in terms of the
motion of the molecules.
For the first time,
there is an understanding,
here, of what gives rise to
pressure, and that is the
velocity or the motion of these
molecules hitting the wall.
That is great.
That is the kinetic theory
result.
But now, Boltzmann also knew
from experiment that P times V
is equal to nRT.
That is the experimental
result, which had been known
already for over a hundred
years.
That is the experiment.
If his theory is correct,
if PV is equal to N m average
velocity squared over three,
it better be equal to nRT.
That will give us,
here, a prediction for what the
velocity of the molecules ought
to be in terms of something
experimentally controllable.
We can see if this kinetic
theory model is correct.
We can solve this for the
average of the velocity squared.
It is equal to 3n RT N over m.
We can go in the laboratory,
vary T and see if,
in fact, the average of the
velocity squared of the
molecules is equal to this
expression here.
That is great.
We have a way to experimentally
check this theory.
And you also see,
here, now, a relationship
between the velocity of the
molecules and this macroscopic
quantity, temperature.
Temperature is related to the
motion of these molecules.
But, before we go on,
this is kind of a messy
expression here.
It has too many n's and m's in
it.
Let me simplify that a little
bit for you.
I am going to simplify this so
that this is 3RT over capital M,
where the following is true.
Over here, n is the number of
moles in the gas.
That is little n.
Big N was the number of
molecules in the gas.
Little m was the mass per
molecule.
All of this is equivalent to
one over big M,
where big M was kilograms per
mole.
You can convince yourselves of
this equality.
I am taking all these N's and
m's and making one big M.
That is my expression,
here.
I have the average of the
velocity squared equal to 3RT
over M.
But this quantity is the
average of the velocity squared.
It is more convenient for us to
talk about a quantity
proportional to the velocity and
not the velocity squared.
What I am going to do is take
the square root of it.
That is simple.
I now have the square root of
the average of the velocity
squared.
That is the square root of 3RT
over M.
I am going to call that the
root mean square velocity.
I am going to put an rms here
as a subscript for the velocity.
It is the root mean square
velocity.
I wanted to talk about a
quantity proportional to the
velocity, instead of the
velocity squared.
That is all I did there.
That is the root mean square
velocity.
But the other big thing about
it is you can see,
for the first time,
now we have got,
and Maxwell had,
an understanding of what
temperature was.
Temperature is related to the
motions of the molecules.
Temperature is related,
in this way,
to the speed of the molecules.
Those are the two important
results.
And this kinetic theory makes a
prediction for what those
velocities ought to be.
In addition,
the temperature is a measure of
the kinetic energy of the
molecules.
How is that?
Well, it is for this reason.
Here is the expression we
derived from the kinetic theory.
And then here is an expression
that I just wrote down,
that says the average kinetic
energy of a molecule is one-half
M, where M is kilograms per
mole, times the average of the
velocity squared.
If I substitute the average of
the velocity squared into here,
I get three-halves RT.
This is telling us,
right here, that the
temperature is also a measure of
the kinetic energy of these
molecules.
We are getting a microscopic
view, here, of what temperature
is.
It is related to the motions of
these molecules.
Now, before I go on talking
about this, let me make one big
point.
That is, this expression here,
for the average energy,
notice that it is one-half M
times the average of the
velocity squared.
It is not one-half M times the
square of the average velocity
This is important.
The average energy is not the
square of the average velocity.
Rather, the average energy is
the average of the velocity
squared.
There is a big distinction.
This is because the average
energy is the second moment of
the velocity distribution
function.
Variables don't always
correspond in a one-to-one
manner.
You don't have to understand
that, if this is foreign to you,
but I do want you to know this
is correct.
Now, let me pick up back here.
What I want you to notice is
that the root mean square
velocity has a mass dependence
in it.
What does that mean?
Well, it means the following.
For some constant temperature,
say we pick 300 degrees Kelvin,
the velocity of the molecule is
going to depend on its mass.
And it is inversely
proportional to the mass,
so heavier molecules move more
slowly, lighter molecules move
more quickly.
For example,
helium at 300 degrees Kelvin,
it is cruising along at 3,060
miles per hour at
room temperature.
Xenon, on the other hand,
which is much more massive,
is moving at a measly 534 miles
per hour.
There is a mass dependence
here.
However, there is no mass
dependence to the kinetic
energy.
The kinetic energy,
we saw, was three-halves RT.
You don't see a mass dependence
in here, do you?
The kinetic energy is only
dependent on the temperature.
Whether or not you have helium
or xenon, the kinetic energy of
those atoms is 3.74 kilojoules
per mole at 300 degrees Kelvin.
It does not matter that helium
is moving six times as fast as
xenon.
They both have the same kinetic
energy.
There is no mass dependence in
kinetic energy.
Now you say,
oh, but look at this,
here is a mass,
there is a mass dependence.
No, because you have to
remember that you substitute in
here.
If you square this,
there is an M here,
and that cancels.
There is no mass dependence in
the kinetic energy,
but the velocity is dependent
on the mass.
That is important.
Well, I told you that this was
the kinetic theory result.
That is, that the root mean
square velocity of these
molecules was represented by
this equation.
And, from this equation,
if you calculate at 300 degrees
Kelvin, these are,
in fact, the velocities of
those atoms.
But how do we know this is
right?
How do we go and measure the
velocities or the speeds of
molecules or atoms?
Well, this is the way we do it.
It is called the time-of-flight
technique.
Are we all on board,
here?
Questions?
Okay.
How are we going to do this
time-of-flight technique?
What we are going to do is we
are going to have a little
pinhole here that we can open
and shut really quickly.
We are going to let out a
little pulse of gas.
To measure the velocity of the
molecules, we are literally
going to measure the time it
takes the molecules to fly from
where we let them out to some
detector.
And since we know the distance,
we are going to be able to
calculate the velocity from
that.
The idea is at time t equals 0,
we let out a little pulse of
gas, and then we start a clock
running.
Then we just measure how long
it takes the molecules to fly
from this origin here to this
detector.
And since we built the
apparatus, and we know what L
is, we can calculate the
velocity.
Time-of-flight,
that is what is done.
However, when we let this
little pulse of gas out,
and now we let the molecules
fly to that detector over here,
what happens as a function of
time?
What will happen is that pulse
of gas will spread out because
not all of the molecules or
atoms in that pulse of gas have
the same velocity.
Some of those atoms are moving
faster than the other atoms.
And so, what is going to happen
is that the molecules or atoms
that are moving faster are going
to hit the detector first.
The molecules or atoms that are
moving more slowly are going to
hit the detector at a later
time.
And that is what we also want
to know, this distribution of
velocities.
But in the measurement,
what we are going to measure is
a distribution of times.
Out of our detector,
we are going to have a plot
that looks like this.
This is going to be f of t,
essentially the number of
molecules hitting the detector
at a certain time t versus the
time.
When we first let our pulse of
gas out, that is time t equals
0.
Then, for a while,
there are no molecules hitting
the detector because it takes a
while for them to get over here
to this detector.
But then, all of a sudden,
they start reaching the
detector.
And this is essentially just a
number of molecules that hit the
detector as a function of time.
That number of molecules
increases and becomes a maximum
here at some time,
and then it exponentially
decays, here.
So, this is what we measure.
This is a distribution here of
flight times of the molecules in
this pulse of gas.
Well, that is nice,
but this is a distribution of
flight times.
It is not a distribution of
velocities, and we wanted a
distribution of velocities.
We want to know the velocity,
here, of these molecules.
You know how to convert time,
given the path length,
to velocity,
but it is not so
straightforward because we have
a distribution function.
We have a distribution in time,
and we want to convert that to
a distribution in velocity.
We have to change the variable
here in a distribution function.
How do we do that?
Well, we want this f of t to be
an f of v.
We recognize here that this
distribution in time,
the probability of finding a
molecule between t and t plus
dt, has got to be equivalent to
the probability of finding a
molecule with a velocity between
v and v plus dv.
But to get from one
distribution function to
another, for example,
if we want f of v,
what we have to know is how one
variable changes with respect to
another.
We have this distribution
function f of t,
but we need to know how t
changes with v.
We need dt by dv,
we need that,
so let's get it.
I will tell you why in a
moment.
We know how v changes with t.
We are going to take the
derivative of v with respect to
t and turn things around.
So, dt / dv is proportional to
minus t squared over L.
This is telling us,
essentially,
how the variable t changes with
v.
To every point in our
time-of-flight distribution,
we are going to multiply this
by this, what is called the
Jacobean.
We need this because the time
and the velocity do not
correlate in a one-to-one
manner.
That often happens with two
distribution functions.
If you do not understand what I
just said, it is okay.
This was just some extra.
I do not hold you responsible
for it.
I just changed my variable in
the distribution function.
Yes?
I think in the notes,
I might have had as a
proportionality.
Up here I actually have the
equal sign.
That actually won't matter in
this transformation.
Pardon?
I understand that.
That is fine.
I don't have the equal sign
there.
That is why I left it out
there, I think.
Anyway, this is the velocity
distribution.
You don't have to understand
how I got there.
This is what the velocity
distribution looks like.
It is what is called the
Maxwell-Boltzmann velocity
distribution.
And the bottom line is that
Maxwell and Boltzmann predicted
this, about 1855.
They actually predicted this
distribution function.
We did not predict it.
We did not go through that part
of kinetic theory,
but they predicted it.
However, it was only until 1955
that the technology existed,
fast enough timing and
electronics existed,
to actually measure this
experimentally.
This took a hundred years or so
in order for this distribution
function to actually be
measured, but here it is,
f of v.
First of all,
there is all of this stuff,
which is proportionality
constants.
We will talk about that in a
moment.
But the variable,
here, is v squared
times an exponentially decaying
function with a v squared in
there.
What does that mean?
Well, if you look at the form
of f of v, this v squared is
what gives rise to this increase
in f of v.
Right here, at low velocities,
that is a quadratic,
v squared.
But you are multiplying it by
an exponentially decaying
function with this v squared in
the argument.
And so that is what gives you
this tail.
If you are multiplying a
function that is going up and
one decreasing,
you are going to get a maximum
at some value of v.
That is where the shape of the
Maxwell-Boltzmann distribution
function comes from.
And what this is telling you is
the probability here of finding
a molecule in a gas with a speed
between v and v plus dv.
That is what that is telling
you.
We often characterize these
distribution functions by some
quantities, and one of those
quantities is what we call the
most probable speed.
Here is the distribution
function, and I have the most
probable speed labeled.
The most probable speed,
(v)mp, is simply the value of v
at which the probability is the
largest.
That was like our most probable
value of r in the radial
distribution functions.
That is what the most probable
speed is.
If you wanted to get that
mathematically,
what you would do is take this
distribution function,
take the derivative,
set it equal to zero,
and then solve for v.
That makes that derivative
equal to zero.
The derivative is zero at
maxima or minima.
And then, you would find that
the value of the most probable
speed is the square root of 2RT
over M.
You are not responsible for
taking this derivative and
setting it equal to zero.
You are responsible for knowing
physically what the most
probable speed is.
The fact that it is this value
here, where the probability is
the largest.
It is the most probable value
of v.
And you are responsible for
recognizing this.
I don't ask you to memorize it
or to write it down.
But, if you see it,
you should know what it is.
That is one quantity that we
use to characterize this
distribution function.
Another quantity that we use is
the average speed,
v bar, average speed.
And the first thing that you
see is that the average speed is
a little bit higher than the
most probable speed.
It is a little bit larger.
Why is that?
Well, it is a little bit larger
because on these
Maxwell-Boltzmann distribution
functions, there are molecules
way out here that have very high
speeds.
There are not a lot of
molecules that have very high
speeds, but there are molecules
with very high speeds.
And so, when you average over
this distribution function,
because there is such a long
Boltzmann tail here,
is what it is called,
the average velocity is going
to be a little higher than the
most probable velocity.
That is physically why the
average velocity is a little bit
larger than the most probable
velocity.
That is important.
If I wanted to calculate what
the average velocity is,
I would take the distribution
function, multiply it by v,
and then integrate over the
range of v, which is zero to
infinity.
You don't have to do that,
but the quantity that you would
get, if you had done that,
is the square root of 8RT over
pi M.
It is larger than the most
probable value.
And then, finally,
the other way we characterize
the distribution function is by
this root mean square speed that
we have already talked about a
lot.
That root mean square speed,
here, is even a larger value
than the average velocity or the
average speed.
And the reason for that is,
again, because of this
Maxwell-Boltzmann tail.
We have molecules here that
have very high speeds.
We don't have a lot of
molecules with high speeds,
but we have very high speeds.
When we take that speed and we
square it, and then take the
average, they make a big
contribution,
and they push this root mean
square speed even higher than
the average speed.
Again, if you wanted to
calculate what that is,
you would take v squared,
multiply it by the distribution
function, integrate it over all
values of E, and you would get
what we got before,
the square root of 3RT over M.
Bottom line here,
for argon at 300 degrees
Kelvin, the most probable speed
is 353 meters per second.
For argon at 300 degrees
Kelvin, the average speed is 399
meters per second.
And the root mean square speed
is 433 meters per second.
Here, you can see how these
three quantities increase as you
go from most probable to the
root mean square speed.
And, in fact,
no surprise,
if you actually go and measure
the argon speeds distribution
function and then evaluate these
characteristics,
you find that indeed those
measurements agree with what Mr.
Maxwell and Mr.
Boltzmann predicted in 1850,
1855.
No surprise.
Back to this distribution
function.
We saw how to characterize it,
but I want to talk about a
couple of other parameters that
it has in it.
It has in it the mass,
and it has it in the
temperature.
Let's talk about what this
distribution function looks like
for different masses and
different temperatures.
That is the general form,
but different masses and
different temperatures.
Let's start by keeping the
temperature constant,
300 degrees Kelvin.
And now, we are going to look
at the distribution functions
for three different masses,
and I am going to plot that.
Here it is for xenon.
What you can see is xenon,
very narrow distribution.
Here it is for argon,
lighter mass,
broader distribution.
Here it is for helium,
really broad distribution.
Well, first of all,
you can see that the average
speed of helium is much greater
than it is for argon,
than it is for xenon.
Because we already saw that it
was inversely proportional to
the square root of the mass.
But the other thing to note is
how broad the distribution is
for helium compared to xenon.
And that is the general case.
The lighter masses have broader
distributions.
Helium is so broad,
meaning that there are helium
atoms here that are so fast that
this is the reason why there is
relatively little helium and
hydrogen in our atmosphere.
That is because,
at our temperatures,
there are enough molecules with
high enough velocities to escape
the earth's gravitational pull,
because they are here at the
tail end.
And so, the helium and the
hydrogen leave our atmosphere.
Unlike Jupiter,
which is 300 times more massive
than the earth,
where the gravitational pull is
greater.
And, in that case,
then those helium atoms don't
have enough velocity to escape
the earth's gravitational pull.
So, that is mass.
What about temperature?
Now we are going to keep the
mass constant and we are going
to look at temperature.
Here is the distribution
function at 100 degrees Kelvin,
pretty narrow.
Here is the distribution
function for argon at 300
degrees Kelvin,
broader.
Here is the distribution
function at 1000 degrees kelvin,
broader again.
You see that as we increase the
temperature, the average speed
increases.
As we increase the temperature,
the width of that distribution
function increases.
Now, one thing to note here is
this is a probability.
The areas under these curves
have to all add up to one.
If this distribution function
is going to move to higher
velocities as we increase the
temperature, well,
of course this maximum
probability is going to have to
go down because we cannot lose
any molecules.
All the area under this curve,
at 100 degrees Kelvin,
has to equal the area under
this curve, at 1000 degrees
Kelvin, because this is a
probability that we are plotting
here.
That is our description of the
Maxwell-Boltzmann distribution.
See you on Friday.